oh yeah folks we're back know weeks off
nothing and we got a big old start for
you it's david dobrik and let's look at
the thumbnail i made for his episode i
always create a new logo custom for the
guest and his is made out of a big old
stack of dry ice blocks that's because
he and I have done some reckless crap
with dry ice you're gonna hear all about
it
it's wild ride let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen david dobrik yeah
dude thank you for having me a man it's
it's an honor
I've been essentially begging you to do
this and and thank you so much for doing
you've always been so good to me and
you're like I'm trying to think of
somebody who came out of YouTube and I
suppose you could count with the divine
origins right but who has had such
incredible like mainstream crossover
coming out of YouTube like it's like
that it's pretty remarkable man I mean
of course everybody knows who Logan Paul
is you know and Jake Paul as well but
you know without putting those guys down
there are more infamous than famous it's
it's sort of negative scandals that have
given them the the mainstream attention
and it's just like I can't think of a
time when I've heard anything even
remotely negative have you ever had any
kind of a scandal have I ever had a
scone yeah there's stuff there ZAF
leapin times were like I like things
have come up that like I've tweeted
before when I was like really young and
stupid and and yeah I don't know I
always think that's such like BS when
like someone gets like [ __ ] for
something they tweeted five or six years
ago because that's like you know I was I
was in high school and I was saying the
stupidest [ __ ] ever like there's sure
half of half of my vocabulary that I
used to say nice cool like I do not say
anymore and it's just people grow but
I'm unfortunately that you know everyone
gets to see me do it online so that
can have some I have some repercussions
but but yeah I'm learning from it just
like everybody else and I know I will I
know I'm definitely going to have some
sort of scandal in the future I don't
know what it is but I know it's coming
and I'm sorry apologies if I just drew
attention to some negative stuff that's
because anything I can't stand
I've been largely I have been largely
scandal-free
you know like there's there's very even
all of my extensive criminal arrests I
mean sure I'm not proud of the drunk
driving you know back in the 90s felony
cocaine possession isn't something I'm
really like proud of but it's my past
you know that's that's where I come from
that's like what made me who I am and my
god did they have twitter back then plus
I've been clean and sober since the
video camera became like a part of
everybody's [ __ ] wardrobe yeah yeah
so it's so interesting it's like it's
like imagine if yeah Majan if you grew
up with Twitter and like it just back in
the day it's crazy how I used to go to
parties people didn't have like cell
phones on them and they couldn't record
everything and like things were like
kept a secret but now like you can you
know you do one slip-up no matter who
you are there's somebody cross the
street recording you or something right
so like everything it's a lot more like
scrutinized which is good in some way
but also like it's harder it's harder to
learn from your mistakes when it's so
public and like everyone's giving you
[ __ ] for it when I was in high school we
had those disposable Kodak cameras and
so you know you take a picture and you
take a picture it's like thank God those
are stored those are coming back though
like I have like I've been using I use
like the Fujifilm disposable cameras and
I started an Instagram page called
David's disposable and it's all it's all
disposable pictures and they're like
making like a serious comeback because
people my friends would like they'd have
like these big parties and they put like
a hundred of them out on the tables and
then everyone got super [ __ ] up and
drunk and they would all take pictures
and in the morning they would just
collect all the cameras and then there'd
be all this like basically [ __ ] new
to the pornography on all these [ __ ]
cameras
when the gound developed and no one
remembered any of it and like I think
that's really cool so they're making a
comeback and I have a it's a little bit
of a tradition on this podcast I never
introduce my co-host Scott Randolph how
you doing good to see you again
actually for the first time we've got
two co-hosts in the van arguably even
more attractive Brisky over here we call
him a young [ __ ] and I can see you yeah
what's up David you can't see me I'm
off-camera
Fred you hear his voice how sexy it is
yeah
this voice sounds better than than all
of us combined so yeah I do have high
hopes for how you look wave to you David
can you get in a yeah and speaking of
sexy where you had John Stamos in the
car recently how is he the voice matches
the face dude John Stamos I think is is
one of the most interesting people
because he's like he's he's John Stamos
there's no way to describe him but like
like we'll go out into public and like
just the way he interacts with people
it's always like he's in a sitcom like
he's like he will forever be that
good-looking guy like even like when he
we went to like Universal Studios for
like five minutes and I remember him
like interacting with the person that
like was valeting our car and it was
like like because you butterflies in
your stomach it was so interesting
watching such a beautiful human just
like taking on the world like life has
to be a lot easier for John Stamos she's
how the hell does he look like that at
his age it makes no sense I know he's
People magazine's sexiest man alive for
every single year since People magazine
he has been Rob Lowe probably Rob Lowe
got to see I don't even know about
Rob Lowe all I know is John Stein was I
John came to one of my shows in Chicago
I would do like these podcast shows and
my mom met him and I've never
seen my mom like put on this kind of
behavior it's so uncomfortable like
genuinely she was like you could tell
that like right in front of my dad she
was like Tyrion Singh these things that
like just being around Johnson was for
the first time it was so bizarre and I
was like holy [ __ ] this man has
superpowers celebrity that probably
happens to them daily hang out like
these incredibly like superstar
personalities they've never had like
really a scandal let me get down to it
you know there's never been any negative
publicity surrounding you but you're not
like going out of your way to be
particularly squeaky-clean or anything
right I mean you're like hey YouTube I'm
throwing three pounds of weed like a
totally yeah I don't know I think it's
like I but there's there's waste there's
ways I feel like my videos and like
everything I portray online like I try
to be as a hundred and ten percent
authentic as I could possibly be and yes
that'll sometimes involve you know me
being mean to my friends or you know
making fun you know make you find my
friends or there's some weed involved
there were doing some kind of a little
stunt in the backyard yeah it's
definitely it definitely rides like the
edge of it but um but I think I have a
good group of friends around me that
like know like to like when I should
like tone it back or like when okay
David like calm down and I've just
learned so much I learned so much from
other people's mistakes too so like
seeing other people on the internet like
[ __ ] up and say sir and [ __ ] that they
shouldn't or like you know make videos
about certain things like that like I
take all that like that's the best to
learn from other people's mistakes cuz
you get all the learning and you don't
get the you don't get the backlash of
making a mistake yeah yeah yeah I'll
tell you this man like it's been such
like such a decision on or such a
privilege and such a help to have been
in a number of your videos I do don't
don't even say that
stop it yeah I mean it because here's
the thing like if there are very few
things I've
that have inspired people as I walk
through my daily life to comment about
it like dude I saw you in david dobrik
vlog I mean it's up there with being on
the Joe Rogan podcast you know like when
and and both but I mean back in the day
when I was on Howard Stern all the time
that would be a big one but dude not
compared to being on david dobrik vlog
or the Joe Rogan experience and it's
just it's just badass man and and and
people who bring up your upon your vlogs
so frequently what's david dobrik like
what like what's he what's he like
I'm like you know yeah that's him you
know I think you know I think that
there's like you know objectively I
think that you know like when were when
we're talking away from from cameras
they get you're you're like
laser-focused and you know but then
again that reads in your vlogs too you
know so right I I have one of the most
interesting interaction because I've
ever had with his celebrity was I feel I
feel like it was you I'm not gonna argue
with David because I am an interesting
guy and the story he's about to tell you
is fantastic also super crazy is the
discussion we have about the dangers of
showing your house to a massive audience
because it tends to end up with really
creepy weird people showing up at or in
David's case inside your house so I'm
just a maniac to be standing here right
in my bedroom on camera but I don't care
because I want you to see my mattress
it's so killer from helix yeah that's
the reason I look so darn good because
I've been sleeping like a champ and
here's what I want you to do take their
little quiz right go to helix sleep calm
/ devo couldn't be easier just a couple
minutes you fill out this quiz and
they're gonna tell you what the perfect
mattress is for you and trust me they
got it right for me I love this thing
and at helix
sleep calm / devo died by using that
with
the / devo you get up to $200 off any
one of their mattresses any mattress and
if you do that here Hilux pillow dopest
pillow in the world they give you two of
them for free if you buy any mattress so
I'm just saying you got nothing to lose
take that sleep quiz at helix sleep calm
/ devo get yourself a killer deal
because you deserve it and that is the
best mattress ever now when you came
over we were doing dry ice in the
backyard and you came over I think you
had like flip-flops on you brought your
dog and you just look like you look like
a neighbor from across the street that
was just interested in what we were
doing I remember you were just sitting
in a lawn chair as we were putting the
dry ice like around the pool and like as
a joke I came over to you and I was like
something about the roof I was like hey
you should I was like when are you gonna
jump off that roof and your response to
me it was like well I'm a little worried
about the shingles cuz I may slide right
off of it but I feel like if I go around
the back like oh like you went straight
into like steve-o mode and I was like
what cuz like the way the way he were
like presenting yourself when you first
came I was like oh he's just coming to
hang out and then literally 10-15
minutes later you're you're doing the
front flip off the roof and so cool that
you can't even see because there's so
much dry ice it was so I saw that story
to so many people cause I thought that
was so interesting that [ __ ] was so
creepy I mean it was so creepy to jump
into a pool that you can't see that I
actually like kind of in my view ruined
the whole thing because I waited until
the the whatever it's off dry ice steam
smoke whatever you want to call it I
waited until it dissipated enough for me
to actually be able to see the pool
because you wish out I [ __ ] press
down and you did that so you you do this
thing where you count from three at one
two three go is my routine for stunts
one two three go right and like you told
me about your rule where you go one two
three go and the second you start
counting you've never backed out from
any stunts never and it's like so on my
videos we never do like stunts like you
do like we'll do like very minimal
things like the smallest of like
little bits and like every time
someone's scared and do something I'm
like dude do what steve-o does two three
oh and just do it and everyone goes one
two three go and then they go okay no
one can follow what you do I think that
is and it's the best thing that you have
that setup because it's like it's
bulletproof at this point like you ain't
mastered it was the first time you did
that
oh [ __ ] man I mean early on I was very
one-dimensional as a performer I would
only jump off roofs and buildings sorry
I was just on rooftops like jumping into
like 12 years old you're like do it like
like when was the first time I got
serious about becoming a stuntman as
I've failed out of the University of
Miami so like 18 19 years old would have
been the origin of 1 2 3
that's one became a thing for sure so
let me correct you there if I if I may
like you say we do very minor small
stunts like I mean it may be like as far
as like physical bodily harm and Damned
maybe but dude the stunts you do are
[ __ ] massive like for example we had
a random meeting to come up with ideas
for deferred for jackass and I'm pretty
comfortable saying this because if we
determined that it was not doable but
but your video was was presented as like
what can we do with this and it was a
where's think the the goop it was an
explosion of like foam what what was
that right right yeah it was um it was
elephant toothpaste basically so it's
like hydrogen peroxide and like
dishwater they blow up and it like it
falls out and it died my entire backyard
right now is still dyed green because
anything it touches
you cannot repaint over because the
chemicals will just see past it so my
back here it's green still because of it
but yeah yes but that got brought up in
a meeting
yeah and it becomes like physically hard
right like there's you know no oh it
doesn't make it no red or something like
it's hot
for the first like millisecond it comes
out of the tube and then and then the
second it like flies away you can
literally swim in it after like it
touches the ground okay so that's really
interesting and I remember this is this
is such [ __ ] I have like a neighbor
like that lives a couple houses down
that like just hates the fact that
there's a youtuber living on the street
so I remember we did that experiment and
the police came like a month later
saying that this guy basically wants to
sue me because when I did the elephant
toothpaste experiment a part of like the
toothpaste landed on his wife while she
was in the hot tub and burned her and
and and I knew that that was [ __ ] so
we like looked at the drone footage and
not only was there no one in his hot tub
but the hot tub like had a cover on it
and on top of that even if the foam made
it to her like it wouldn't have like
done anything with her and that that's
like a fun story that came out of that
like cases yeah like I hate when people
just like yeah try to ruin somebody's
day for no reason this because they're
bored it's just a question of honesty
man like honesty integrity decency I
think those are my three and the guy was
being dishonest and malicious so yeah
I'm angry too
I do want to I do want to say um I do
want to say though like sometimes people
come up to me and like they'll describe
my videos to like a stranger right in
front of me and they'll be like it's
sort of it's sort of like jackass meets
this and and I always go like no like I
we don't do anything that dangerous like
dude like none of my friends would be
able to repeat any like if I put B's in
a limousine my my friends would have
never talked to me again I would love to
do it but they would never look in my
direction and like it's I just feel like
it's I'm doing like every time someone
compares me to jackass they're like
doing a disservice to the jackass I get
it I get it and I'll give you more
credit than that I think the spirit of
what you're doing is just so like just
riled it's it's wild you know and and
it's wild and I think whether what makes
it
really kind of works so well and we've
been so successful at least part of it
is that you're able to not take yourself
very seriously and I think that that's
like the that's like the backbone of
what made jackass work because we
weren't like a bunch of macho guys like
oh yeah like trying to look cool like we
were okay with not looking cool you know
and there's something there's something
really endearing about that and I think
you possess that big-time also you do
like like huge scale epic stuff you know
and I'm so interested I think I was
checking out the the going through the
car wash in a convertible and we did
that right we did that jackass where I
was on the hood of the car like in my
and my cheetah print bikini and they
drove it through the carwash but but
before doing that go through the car
wash thing and by the way going through
in a convertible it's just classic I
mean that's such a notch above jackass
so it's a convertible
I've seen the car wash convertible thing
done like like a bunch of times and I
knew it like originated from one of them
you guys it did it I was on the hood of
my car which was a big Grand Marquis was
totally not a convertible so you stepped
it up like humongous I think being on
the hood is a lot scarier because when
those things come down and they're going
you put the car like when it's the the
entertainment of it is you know the fact
that the cars being filled with soap and
water
but right the thing was before we did
the carwash they they they didn't like
whatever they do some research and they
were like whoa maybe the carwash people
said you there's chemicals in there that
you can't spray on your body so before
we went before they drove me through the
carwash
they like disabled a bunch of the Jets
that had the crazy chemicals in it and I
have to know if you guys contaminate my
friends for the rest of their lives
no I don't know I I remember we were
kind of friends with the carwash lady
and she was just like yeah go for it but
she was super cool about it so I should
know about chemicals the funny thing was
we we didn't have a convertible so we
looked on Craigslist for like a cheap
one and instead of buying it we just
told the lady we're like we're gonna run
it through a carwash can we give you 400
bucks and just give it back to you and
yeah and she was like okay so she sat
outside the carwash as we took her
convertible through the carwash and gave
him right back to her after and that was
it the most burning question you got to
love david dobrik because when you put
him on the spot he delivers with honesty
and i'm gonna get honest with you now -
a while back I got fat and I posted on
every social media platform pictures and
video of just what a slob I had become
and I got tired of it so I'm back to
exercising it's going pretty well
I'm already in much better shape and
it's a lot easier when I'm jamming out
to tunes while I'm working out and I
made a promise to all of you a while
back that if you catch me anywhere any
time for the next year and I don't have
my rake on earbuds in my pocket ears or
both that I will record your voicemail
greeting a shout-out video to your
little buddies or your girlfriend your
boyfriend and I don't care about making
that promise because I will not get
caught without my rake on every day e 25
earbuds in my pocket because I love them
they fit right in my ear I can take on
and off my sweaty clothes after my
workout and it's not like they're
falling out I could even lay my head on
my pillow and it's perfectly comfortable
while I'm listening and they've got
buttons to control the tracks pause skip
track all that and like I don't know
about other earbuds Wireless ones that
have that and these are half the price
of any other premium wireless earbuds
they sound just as good they last for
six hours but when you put them back in
the case the case charges them up so it
feels like they last forever god I can't
enough how much I love these rakin
earbuds and if you go to buy rake on
comm slash Stevo you're gonna get 15%
off of your whole order yeah that's
right again
15% off of your whole order if you go to
buy rake on Comm / Stevo just give it a
shot man because these things are dope
now let's get to the burnin question in
your videos what you do in your videos
just routinely it's just give away cars
like you're giving away more cars than
Oprah III don't think I have she gave it
to her entire audience right well I'm
not like it's just it's just fascinating
and and like particularly it's it's
interesting that you've only put up one
video on your main channel since the
coronavirus shut down which it's a
little bit of an interesting
counterintuitive decision because in the
coronavirus shut down it just seems like
everybody's got more time to be watching
youtube videos
I think views are up and like you know
you know like people could use the
entertainment I mean I know that I've
been like considerably more active ended
right yeah so the reason I'm doing that
is because so first of all I don't hang
out I'm not seeing anybody during this
quarantine and it's like and you know I
have like when it first started and I
got like some serious backlash for for
even seeing my friends who are basically
my next-door neighbors which many people
don't know but so yeah so it's tough to
make those videos without those guys
around and on top of that like the way I
look at it is like so Jimmy Fallon right
has like moved his show into his into
his like bedroom or into his room right
and like he could he can do that because
at the end of all this he's going to
bounce back to that studio so even if
people don't like this version to me
Fallon he's gonna be able to go back to
that high production quality stuff and
people are gonna know the difference
like Oh Jimmy's back
but I feel like if I start posting
during this quarantine just by default
my contents gonna be so watered down
because this is gonna be me inside in my
house and people are slowly gonna be
more and more disinterested and there's
never going to be a moment where they're
gonna be like Oh David's back to doing
the regular stuff right so I'd rather
just like quit cold-turkey and stop and
then when I'm able to make the videos I
want to make exactly the way I want to
make them then I'll start again I just
don't want there to ever be a time like
is or his videos still like in his
bedroom or like is he back to you a
microphone is it is it a nice break for
you to take a break from like doing the
uploads or you kind of want to get back
to it it's a little bit of both like III
I've never been happier than when I've
been I used to do three a week I was
like the most I was doing it like two or
three years and I was so stressed out
like I was editing too like 6:00 in the
morning and then I woke up at 11:00 to
shoot the next one and I was doing this
for you know four years and like that
was the happiest I've ever been like
being so stressed out were you just like
you feel like you're just being squished
in a box but doing something you love is
so like undeniably amazing it's like our
gas vehicle I was like there's no better
way to describe it like getting to do
what you love and getting to do it so
consistently and seeing such positive
feedback is like the best feeling I got
to do that and then I and then I went
back to two week and I remember him I
remember my friend was like you're gonna
feel really weird cutting back on your
pose and once I did I felt like I had no
purpose anymore like I felt like I like
I felt like I wasn't part of like
humanity and then I like went back and
like I was a human again it was really
bizarre like letting up on the gas and I
needed to do it but I'm also kind of
bummed I did it I don't know wow I
really did that so so much like just
seeing the incredible pressure like
people I like if somebody asked me are
you happy and I say like like as a
person like my pretty much no you know
like no I'm not [ __ ] happy because
because like if I was happy I would be
like I don't know I'd be comfortable I'd
be content I'd be like no like I have
this like this built in like discontent
like I've this bit this ambition like I
want like I want to accomplish so much
that it's impossible for me to be happy
and kind of the closest I get is the
satisfaction of being unhappy but like
working you know I worked quite a bit
but they added yeah and there's
something so special about like about
like finishing a project and then and
like you know people are watching that
while you're making the next one like
there's something I feel so good about
that I like there's people consuming
this and I'm here working on the next
one that people don't know about yet
that people can be excited for like
that's just like an unbeatable feeling
and I'm sure you guys are well aware
that for sure and and when you're
dealing in in digital contents like
there's analytics there's like how it
performs it's like when people have a
movie opening at the box office you have
like you know a box office open you find
out how you did and but we like it's
crazy I want to ask about like all the
stuff that you give away but like but
before that just your philosophy of
YouTube is is really fascinating because
for all the people out there I don't
want to name names but they drive me
nuts with their like 20 minute long
video and nothing happens it's like the
title of the video promises something
like really outrageous the thumbnail is
equally misleading and then it's 20
minutes that you have to sit there to
find out that it wasn't even true it was
like and and contrary to that your
videos are all like seemingly randomly
four minutes and 20 seconds long and
there's more [ __ ] loaded into your four
minutes and 20 seconds it's almost
frustrating they're like [ __ ] you know
like you get david blaine over to your
house and that gets like thirty seconds
and it's like [ __ ] that other people
would make you know they were better
people would be like this is the 20
minutes of gold there'd be like a series
of David hanging at the house I was I
was just talking to David Blaine about
that David was like well first off let
me say this I filmed with John Stamos I
we went to Warner Brothers and we went
on a
line we drove around like he was in the
he was like the tour guy like giving a
tour to like all these fans of Warner
Brothers whatever and we filmed for like
3-4 hours and I posted the video and I
used like anywhere between 15 to 20
seconds from filming for four hours and
John calls me and he goes what the [ __ ]
he was so confused he's like that's it
he wasn't mad but he was just like
where's the rest of it and I was like
well that was the best moment like that
interaction was like the moment I want
to keep like I want to highlight that
moment and like realize like that's the
way to do it is the best but I was
talking to David Blaine too about this
and he was he's he just finds digital
media so interesting because because
like back then he was he was telling me
how like he could come out with the
special and he could coast off that for
like a year or two right like he could
get like that is his sting like that's
his baby they like for two years people
will be like oh yeah David Blaine did
this that this but now when you post
something you have like four hours and
then it's like their embrace occupied by
something new and it's so so crazy or
fast it's moving right I mean to that
point like that used to be called
overexposure
if you showed up too frequently and too
much stuff it was a bad thing like we
have not use the word overexposed as
like a term of the celebrity is never
overexposed it's just it's just crazy
how I remember I had no idea when we did
this this stunt the first time was dead
jumped off the roof into the the dry ice
which way which was it was pretty cool
it was fun and you know I'm not gonna
beat myself up for being too much of a
wimp but then I forget who reached out
to who but I wanted to do something or
when we decided we were gonna film it
again at some point
hello [ __ ] up when we met us there I was
after the next time we were somehow we
determined okay let's get together make
a video and I was like okay dude I'll
buy a hot tub so I bought like this
$8,000 hot tub and jumped up through for
my house but my plan was that I was
going to feel the hot
with dry ice you know I like almost like
a I don't even know why I was thinking
that but like I was like ah before we
put the dry ice and let me do a test
jump just to make sure you know test it
out see what it's like before I can't
see the [ __ ] thing and like and it
was like that's gonna make like my worst
injuries ever video like that was like
jumping off the roof of my house into
that [ __ ] hot tub is among the worst
injuries you probably broke your butt
dude you ever get x-rayed for that and
the thing was I was like all cabe [ __ ]
okay so we'll just make it what would
change the idea I didn't get it for that
I was like what change the idea so that
the purpose of jumping in the hot tub
was just to get me wet for the slip and
slide and I'm trying to tell him how to
film his video like all bull do this and
David David's like no really I don't
need that you know like Tim what Scott
said what a boss [ __ ] move and I
think that that's why I think that's why
you do so well with with your audience
because you don't [ __ ] waste their
time where you're not stretching [ __ ]
out I think people genuinely appreciate
that and I try to what sounds like you
know your art a lot you know you know
exactly what you want and in you you
want to fit it into a you know certain
way of doing things that you don't give
a [ __ ] what anybody else says you know
and you do it it's like is like on vine
I came from vine so I knew that
everyone's attention span was already
sure right everybody was at six seconds
so then on YouTube like okay this is how
fast everything is moving so let's say
Steve oh let's say steve-o is going to
jump off a roof into fire right in in a
regular YouTube video and like a regular
vlog you have you'd set it up and then
you'd go to the hole you'd go to Home
Depot and you buy the logs for the fire
and you buy the ladder you'd show all
that so then in my video I was like okay
let me just show I'll introduce steve-o
and I'll say what he's doing so that's
what my video is but now with the
tic-tock it's gotten so much quicker
where I wouldn't even have any time to
introduce steve-o I would just show him
doing it like it's gotten that like
people
even care about the intro anymore like I
think it's getting so much faster that
it's just like Oh peas jumping that's it
like rather than like hey this is Steve
oh he's gonna jump from that roof and
landing that fire no time for that
anymore like it's straight to the action
it's crazy like how much faster and
faster and faster things are going
because of like people's attention spans
gonna say you're on you're on
tick-tock I take it yes i dude are you
on have you just too much man
snapchat tick-tock Instagram stories
Steve Facebook live crushed me correctly
you need to be on tick-tock it is
perfect for you it's it's literally it's
Nickelodeon cartoon network Disney
challenge all those combined for like
the amount of eyes that kids it has over
1.5 billion downloads it's the most
downloaded app on the entire App Store
that's insane over Twitter Instagram
like it's the place to be and the
algorithm is so good on the app and it's
also funny and it's like it has
something for everybody like my my my
home feed it's all it's all just funny
videos but then you go to my assistants
and it's every single video you scroll
past all cats because she loves watching
cats and caters to you it totally caters
and learns everything you like and you
don't like so if you spend like a week
on it the app is gonna be completely
customized to you and you're gonna love
it like that's that's all it is give it
a chance the guy went on a walk with
today he's like 65 he's like dude do you
do tick tock I'm like no he's like I
[ __ ] love that yeah like David Blaine
will send me pic talks and I'll be like
what like the fact that David Blaine is
sending me tic-tac videos of people
dancing that he enjoys I'm like oh my
god anybody can love this I mean yeah I
just honestly like what you say carries
weight with me I believe and I think I
remember I got an account but I just
didn't by the time this airs
so everybody can go to Bebo take cars
did you already get it I got it but I
was
like the back to the YouTube thing yeah
like it's really really interesting
we're talking about the the philosophies
of sort of digital platforms and your
point about not making videos because
you'd be worried that a watered down
version of videos that aren't quite as
good would be somehow disrespectful that
it would bring we would undermine the
goodwill that you've built with your
audience but right typically the
philosophy of YouTube is quantity over
quality and so like it's like you know
it's interesting that I think there's a
lot of integrity and no I'm not gonna
put anything out there and then when I
come back I'm gonna come back but you
almost when you do come back have to
like get the ball rolling and you have
to prove yourself all over again it's
like it's like you've never done YouTube
in the beginning you have to you have to
win over these people all over again so
yeah in a couple months when everything
resumes yeah I'm gonna have to put in
140 percent effort and proof to people
that like hey David still fun to watch
you have a bunch of ideas you've been
sitting on I do you know he does dude
zero no hi guys I can't explain this to
you
there is never we have never after a
video is done that is all of our ideas
thrown into that video we are completely
completely out there's no like notepad I
have with ideas it's just all out the
window and for three years when I was
doing it like [ __ ] would happen every
day
and I was getting so confused I was like
like so I'd run out of ideas and then
the next day a guy broke into my house
he was sitting in my living room so I
filmed him and then I ran out of ideas
again and then the next day my upstairs
neighbor at my apartment was throwing
beer bottles at people and he threw a
beer bottle right at my car and like
[ __ ] was just happening there's
something about like when you're in it
but like the universe is like aligning
with you and like giving its [ __ ] yeah
III saw it and he started yeah I saw on
the news that he had an intruder I got
news yes that what yeah that wasn't even
it that was that was just a guy in my
backyard that's normal but there was one
time I walk
into my house and there was a guy
wearing my clothing for my closets
sitting on my couch and he [ __ ] all over
my living room furniture and he took all
his clothes off and he was passed out on
one of my couches and I remember like
grabbing a knife and grabbing my camera
I'm going to film him and then calling
the police and it was just like it was
like this Little Miss thing [ __ ] fell
in my lap was the other time yes a white
man we use a fan yeah no I think I think
he was just crazy I live on a dead end
so when like when like crazy people just
go for walks my house is the last house
so they're just like I got to go inside
I'm curious about you guys I saw a video
clip I don't know when it was but you
guys were driving the wrong way at LAX
Airport and you got pulled over was that
granel yeah that well that wasn't my do
you know wasn't my idea but it was yeah
that was that was a moment that was
literally that was exactly what I'm
describing like it was like I remember I
was going to the airport and I was like
I do not have enough for this vlog I was
so stressed out I was like I got a post
this as soon as I land in New York and I
remember Natalie went down the wrong way
at LAX and at the end of the wrong way
ran right into a police officer and he
turned on his headlights and she got
pulled over and I was like this is crazy
that this should happen just now there's
like something about I don't know
there's something about like being in
intensity of it that like so many things
are happening around you but at the same
time you have to be careful and not get
lost in it and film like stupid stuff
that that'll get you in trouble yet did
you guys get in trouble for the airport
thing or die's like just get the [ __ ]
out of here yeah he wasn't get the [ __ ]
out of here and Natalie like genuinely
made that mistake and she's a horrible
driver
so it was and it was very evident when
she was talking to the police officer
she was like I'm so sorry I [ __ ] up so
yeah aha okay I got a you said about not
having ideas and I relate to that too
but I do have like big ones that I plan
for down the road and when I saw the
your body with the the makeup artist
gave me tits
and yeah it broke my heart because one
of my
major things on my to-do list is to
actually get like full like breast
implants like you know oh we didn't do
that that was makeup I know I know I
know I know but the thing is like in my
mind what justifies doing that I mean
it's a [ __ ] crazy stunt super gnarly
I know that that was just makeup but I
was like you know everything that I
think is really valuable about it like
all of the gags that you can do where
it's like you know you crop out the head
like you guys accomplished that without
the actual surgery right for me I'm like
I'm just so stubborn like I'm doing it
that's funny
as getting prosthetics like hitting like
sorry getting like real like a real boob
job that was definitely an idea we had
and that was one of those ideas that was
like vetoed by like everybody my friend
group like are you [ __ ] down that was
one of those ideas where like three
steps in and they go yo chill
that's not happening you can't do that I
got everybody saying please do it cuz
I'm so curious how it's gonna look
everybody everybody's saying that to me
no no don't do it and and every one of
those people is like reinforcing to me
that it's an awesome idea was like dude
I'll set you up with the consultation
yeah your mom works for the plastic
doctor I was like hey we have to you you
have to like go see a psychiatrist
because when you do like is like a
gender thing I guess you got the guy has
to check you off and see if you're okay
he's like my guys down so we've covered
this philosophy that you have of YouTube
just lowering an impact just concentrate
and I just subscribe to that so much man
I think that that's so killing and that
means so much and and then this
overwhelming generosity I mean with the
pace that your videos keep there are
there.again
each one is 4 minutes and 20 seconds
they're loaded like that you know that
the little like glimpse you get into
something happening and like to that
point you're giving away cars you see
like a glimpse of two cars with ribbons
on it you're like oh wow ok gave away a
couple more cars and it's just like
onwards and forward you know like and
the last video you put
which is that won't leave video you've
put up since the corona you know shut
down or whatever the lockdown in that in
that video you start out by giving out
Playstations EA sports like like play
consoles and then and then you go to
giving like frisbees with like hundred
dollar bills tapes to them and just
throwing frisbees to people and then it
turns into ten thousand dollar checks
that you're shooting a t-shirt can I
number one how did you how do you make
out a check to somebody is it just like
you sign in and says ten thousand
dollars and they can write their own
name in oh so we had so I I was I'm on
this app called the community app have
you heard of it oh my god is this
another [ __ ] me this I find really
interesting it's called the community
app and it's like yet you'll see a lot
of celebrities like like hacks to me and
then yeah and then so like a little over
200,000 people texted us and they're
like I need help with this and you can
search up key words in the text so I
could look through all the texts that
say help or car or need a ride or need
mortgage so we we we looked at all the
people in our area like within like a
100-mile radius cuz we took an RV so we
went all around California and then
every city we would stop by I we'd have
a list of like seven names that needed
something whether it was just to say
hello and maxbox $10,000 or they need a
new car we made a stop there and we
already had their name so we could
already write it on the tracks you can
just text them here meat is here yeah
and and we would text them back and we'd
be like the carrier's here to give you
some merch so we didn't want out we
didn't want them to know that it was
like me showing up with like money so we
like told them that somebody's dropping
off something just for being like a cool
supporter so that was really cool but I
remember we did yeah we gave a lot of
people like $10,000 for mortgage and I
remember that there was a bunch of
people we didn't even use because like
when you're giving that much amount to
people a lot of times they don't even
they
react because they don't know how to
react to it so I know that we cut out
like a good amount of reactions where
people were just like they couldn't find
words and it just like it didn't it
didn't read on camera so it is a really
interesting thing to do in the video
you've got the checks are wrapped in a
t-shirt then you've got the t-shirt and
the teacher can and when you should hit
them by the way it looks like totally
violent like you nailed them with like
which is funny and then they open it up
and it's like a check for 10,000 bucks
and like the lady starts crying but then
it cuts into almost like a montage you
to see like t-shirts flying boom boom
boom was every one of those t-shirts
like ten thousand dollars yes oh my god
so then so then alright so then we start
giving away cars like right is it do you
do you know what the bottom line budget
was for that whole video there's
something about when you're like like on
earth easy but there's something about
when you're like giving back and you're
in that situation where there almost
doesn't feel like there is a budget
where you're kind of just going and
you're just like [ __ ] I'll figure it
out later I mean and I think that that's
where we found ourselves like we were
just like let's just do it let's let's
as many homes as we can at least three
days let's just hit those homes and
we'll deal with the consequences of the
price later and then there was the time
with the bumbling chicken you're like oh
no way man mention bumbles let me call
the the bumbles CEO and and they will
just start giving [ __ ] away dude who are
you bro I went that was the craziest
yeah we were in the car and and my
friend goes yeah I met my husband I met
my fiancee on bumble and I was like I
wonder if I can call bumble right now
and get like money from them and just
for you saying that and then sure enough
I got a good amount of money from them
and we and I used that on the video yeah
I love it I have a philosophy philosophy
it's such a big word for something so
stupid but I have this like rule where
if I ever do anything branded on my
channel it always goes towards a
surprise of some sort so let's say a
brand gives me two hundred thousand
dollars a hundred and ten thousand
dollars of it it goes
surprised and the rest I keep because of
taxes right so tax is like 50% right so
so every time there's anything branded
on my main channel it's always going
right back into the video dough and that
makes it so easy for everybody I am
happy I got a great video person
receiving is happy because they get a
gift and the brand is happy because
they're part of something cool I mean it
makes perfect sense to me because here
you are like I mean I got to get off my
knees and stop sucking your dick
honestly I see you on either you know
sit next to Jimmy Fallon
you know I like you're on The Ellen Show
right like I'm driving down the road and
you've got [ __ ] like full full on
billboards and like it's it's everybody
everywhere I go people like oh my god I
saw you and David Roberge vlog like
what's he like like and I'm just
thinking [ __ ] this is like the
biggest star to come out of youtube like
it and part of me just wants to get
jealous but then but then I'm like now
I'm pretty good at letting you know and
let go of any of that kind of [ __ ] a
long time ago but I'm just fascinated
with what a huge [ __ ] star you are
and that's why I bugged you like so many
times
yeah hey man dude my pocket there's
anything I can do to you know to make
this empty to like if you want me to
shave all my pubes and smoke them in a
big one like you got I've been crying
for that one idea I was yours yes
steve-o when this is over like I I in a
perfect world I would have you in every
single video because there's there's
definitely room for something like I I
love having a stunt of some sort in
every video imagine a world where every
video of there's like 20 30 seconds of
like just you doing something I would
[ __ ] I mean here I'm saying oh let me
make it up to I'll do like whatever you
want in your videos one meanwhile that's
the most self-serving thing just make
sure you follow me
oh no you should do like you know how
you smoked all those people out with
with the weed you should put people
pubes in there and just [ __ ] smoke
you out a room full of people's pubes
yeah that's that's insane that you guys
smoke pubes
but I remember Stevo showed me somebody
smoking pubes was it you or smoke man
danger was involved you showed him that
yeah I showed him the whole comedy
special that I I talked about that
special that you showed me to my friends
I know it's like top secret or whatever
but can you please send me it so just I
can show it to my friends because I keep
bringing it up and they're like they
really want to see because it's [ __ ]
gnarly like you genuinely like
next-level like I do watch again and
you're like what the [ __ ] we could be as
little as like a week or two from
finally getting it out like that it's
direct-to-consumer model like louis c.k
was known for so ah right oh my god
remember you're showing to your like dog
dude let me do the pubes [ __ ] stunt
dude we got to do it and I was always
feeling protective of it but but yeah
dude you got it let's do a pube bonanza
I've actually been saving my poop my
pubes I've got like two years of
harvesting my own pubes in a ziplock
baggie good yeah I walked upstairs one
day and you and you had this bag of
pubes I'm like dude was that you're like
I've been saving my pubes for two years
I'm like but I'm with you like every day
for the last six years this is just as
been as a dirty little secret
I'm like bro like what is that dude he
just does [ __ ] like that all the time
and sell the rest online see how much
you get for it yeah I mean dude I I've
been
my head against the wall for the longest
time because I do genuinely work you
know and like weaving Scot here's my
tour manager you know he helps me with
my YouTube videos and stuff but like
we've been grinding for six-and-a-half
years now it's like just airport hotel
like check it is it's such a [ __ ]
awful way to live always in the airport
always could go do the same [ __ ]
thing ground hogs day and working so
hard and I look at people like Logan
Paul like people like you know like just
always doing something different and
interesting you know like and just
killing it and I'm like [ __ ] what am I
doing wrong
you know like I'm trying to figure out
how to be more david dobrik more david
dobrik yeah I don't think there's a
secret formula for any of this stuff I
think it's minoo some people upload
every day my buddy Casey nice tat I
don't know if you're tuber he did 700
episodes in a row every single day you
know what that's not like that's he he
would tell me that he'd go to bed at
3:00 and he he'd like sorry he got about
it like yeah you got about three and
then wake up around 6:00 every day every
Saturday reddit post and film so he'd be
editing the vlog I was going up that day
as he's filming the one that's going up
the next day and he did that for seven
hundred days in a row and that was like
that was like the method to his madness
and then I did three week and you know
then I did one a week and that worked
and it's like there's no real secret
formula for like how much work you have
to put into it or like how often you
have to upload but I think what what the
most important part is is just making
the stuff like top-notch quality like
that's all it is
like that's all and the best part about
YouTube it is it's all free so like you
really get rewarded for putting super
quality stuff up there because people
aren't expecting anything and then they
see you you know they see you do some
[ __ ] great [ __ ] that you don't think
one of the movie theater for and they're
like [ __ ] yeah like I want to watch this
thing forever
I'm just tuning on so many people don't
give a [ __ ] I don't let YouTube's are a
bit dude like I just tweaked Rand Paul
the gorgeous guy
thus off-camera he's my he's our our
editor you know and think I can edit too
so we do it sort of together but [ __ ] we
tweaked over every little thing like it
like that the passion we put into it the
work we put into these videos that we
make is is insane and I got it I got one
more thing that I want to ask you that
I'm legitimately curious about I watched
was it architecture design or whatever
some [ __ ] thing they don't actually
digest Architectural Digest and
basically that's like the modern era of
cribs where they it's a YouTube channel
and it's like a tour of the celebrity's
home you know and like in the title
it'll say like how much those home costs
you know and so you know I remember
seeing it like it's just been uploaded
your episode of it they said you know
david dobrik
to 2.5 million dollar mansion you know
like Trevor and I was like oh [ __ ] I
gotta see this you know like I watched
it within like you know a couple hours
of it being posted and I remember it had
a disgusting number of views I was like
the question I have is I guess you've
been pretty like liberal but about
showing you know like I remember asking
you because I was so sensitive when you
came over and we were filming at the
house I was like oh no we've got to
drape this blanket over here I wouldn't
want anyone to be able to see the house
number or anything like and you were
like oh well you know do you have like
security at your house anything like
that like no I don't and it is that is
our biggest problem is like it's like
people coming to the house we call the
police on a guy two days ago cuz he so
once in a while people will come this is
like a normal thing for some reason some
people come with their bags packed and
they've traveled from like a different
state and they're like I've run away
from home I've given up everything I
just want to work for you guys and like
and they'll just be sitting there and
well there was one time we had to call a
person's parent and was like hey your
son's here and the mom was like worried
like we didn't know where he was he's
like yeah your son's here on a front
door he took a bus here like 16 hours
and we had to send them back because
it's just it's such a bizarre thing cuz
especially with the videos people think
that they know us because they let so
many people whole entire life so they
think they're our friends so they think
they can walk up on our property and
it's [ __ ] terrifying it's the worst
it's super invasive it's really really
disrespectful it's really invasive and
like here I I know I'm I know you well
enough that that you like are absolutely
as nice of a guy off camera as you are
on I know 100% that if anybody ever
comes up to you sees you in public that
of course you're gonna take a picture
with them of course you're gonna bend
over backwards to give them a good
experience
and I work really hard to be the same
way but it's like right at my [ __ ]
house like like that's the one it's like
it's like in my hotel room when I'm on
tour and in my [ __ ] house that is
like the one sanctimony safe space like
you know and I reserve the right to not
do [ __ ] mean greets at my house so I
was just dying to know if if like you
know if you had it to do over again
would you do the the arc the ad the you
know would you would you bring that
because it's particularly close to me
because I've been weighing around like
do I do a video of agate or my house I'm
dying to do we've got three goats in our
backyard man like we've got [ __ ]
animals all over the house it's
hilarious I feel like a [ __ ] Pippi
Longstocking I want to show my house but
like I'm scared of bringing like a lot
of attention to this I feel like I can't
make that video without saying hey
before we before I open this [ __ ]
door I want to be really clear you're
not invited to [ __ ] come to my house
I don't want I don't want to get [ __ ]
mail on my house I get bit mail in my
house I'm mad I tear it up I throw it
away it's not getting read and you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you send it you know
[ __ ] you I don't want to be here if you
wanted to Bjorn to see me be nice
anywhere in the world except my [ __ ]
house right yeah no I if I don't have
any regret of like of how much I've
shown of my life or anything like that
especially when it comes to the videos I
made I don't know it's just something
you just have to live with
it's like it's all part of the it's all
part of the game I guess I mean that's
that's just one [ __ ] huge downside I
had a guy come up to my this was like
before the quarantine he knocked on my
door at [ __ ] 11:00 p.m. at night like
I'm on my couch by myself and it's him
and it's like two buddies who are like
in there like late 20s like are these
guys gonna [ __ ] murder me and they
have they have a six-pack and they're
like you want to come drinking with us
I'm like what like no he answered the
door huh yeah I answered the door
because I didn't know what to do and
there's definitely been yeah there's
definitely oh my god oh my god the other
day let me let me tell you this the
other day I so I live like I live on the
corner as I'm describing or 6:00 to 9:00
so I live on the corner like off a hill
and there is I ordered food I ordered
food like I ordered post mates to come
to my house and the drivers coming up
the hill so I was gonna go and I was
gonna go greet him by my front gate but
there was a guy at my gate sitting on
the hood of his car like right outside
with his headlights on right outside my
gate and I freaked out and I was like
hey I don't want this post man it's guy
coming in in here in case there's about
to be some kind of a [ __ ] shootout
so I called my post mace guy and I'm
like wait down the street I'm coming to
you and I was like kind of panicky and
he got scared he's like okay okay what's
going on
so I instead of going from the front I
ran from the back side of my house so I
went down the hill and it was rainy out
so I slid down the entire [ __ ] hill I
ate so much [ __ ] and then I got to my
neighbor's like my neighbor's house his
backyard I hopped the fence into his
backyard
with my phone in my hand and I didn't
realize once I hopped the fence there
would be another hill and I stumbled and
I tripped and I rolled a couple times
down his hill and I phoned flew out of
my hand into his pool and my phone was
cracked so I didn't have any time to
waste so I jumped right into the pool to
get my phone so now I'm [ __ ] drenched
in my in my neighbor's pool at like
11:00 p.m. and then I and I have to hop
his fence to go outside to go onto the
main street so that
find my [ __ ] post mates drivers and
I'm [ __ ] soaked and I'm like thank
you for the food he's so freaked out so
those are the things I have to deal yeah
I was gonna ask you how you've been
doing during the pandemic but I know
yeah yeah I guess yeah but yeah I don't
know if you see if you make that clear
in a video and you go please don't
[ __ ] come to my house it's gonna help
a lot more but just be prepared that
there will always be a couple people
that think that they are the exception
that means that when people do show up
they're really really gonna be me I
don't know that's probably I said it
more just like all like in the moment of
my background [ __ ] I'll probably find a
more articulate and constructive way to
convey that message so do we want to cut
that out of your I watched your Crips
episode literally four days ago I the
one where you're in the apartment in
Hollywood I had a couple there with all
the pillars and stuff yes they're Umbro
those [ __ ] insane that reminded me of
my apartment well obviously not anywhere
close but like the the ramp you had in
the kitchen it was crazy and how many
more how many like shows her movies was
this after that was in conjunction with
the release of the first Jackass movie
so obviously the shows came first right
yeah I I had it was like a sketch I was
like there's no way it's like this is
like the the perfect steve-o setting in
the world I think there's no way this is
real MTV just put that up on YouTube and
I think they put up our whole episode so
Pontius [ __ ] dude cribs out of his
car how classic is that I remember that
he's got he's got a [ __ ] a cross
hanging from the mirror he's like I'm
not religious but I like to hang this
from mirror it keeps the people from
breaking into the car I couldn't be more
grateful for you brother and yet like if
I can smoke pubes anything
to make your videos more entertaining to
get me more attention addicted like
whatever I love everything that we've
done together I'm grateful to call you a
friend and I really I promise I won't
bug you for favors
you know this recession call me whenever
literally I you just have to text me
once or twice and then I'll see it I'm
just I I love doing stuff with you and
I'm i seriously mean it if after this if
there was a way where we could do
something like on a consistent basis I
would absolutely kill for that I would
love it to and as far as like the giving
stuff away thing like gum ii-i've been
saying how I wanna get behind some like
the food drive the food drives man like
it breaks my [ __ ] heart that people
can't eat right now man like it's and
not only that they can't work they they
don't have money they can't afford food
and at the same [ __ ] time groceries
are like skyrocketing in price so like
all this like the food drives with
thousands of cars and miles long lines
breaks my [ __ ] heart so that's
something that I want to get on to maybe
come out of retirement during the
pandemic and he's good he's good we'll
figure it out no but like but like like
a fir video like that like you helped me
with the food drives like that's you
have such a perfect like brand for that
because you can be your own chaotic self
around people that need help like that's
like imagine imagine you're you know
handing a sandwich is somebody at the
same time you're smoking a pube and
they're laughing that's so fun to watch
like it's like pack it all together and
at the same time I am helping others
like I find that so important like I
love doing charity stuff but I like I
like it when you can see their like the
interaction with the person that's
receiving it because I'm like I'm so
weird about charities like I don't know
where the money's going and I don't know
like right how it's done it out like I'd
rather be doing it in person and and it
inspires so many more people to see
people do it in person so like you can
definitely put your own [ __ ] cool
twist on giving back like and it could
be so so fun to watch so yeah I would
I'd love to see something like that from
you yeah
what's why I think that that's something
we gotta get on man and yeah thank you
again how many podcasts have you done
like other people's one night no no you
have your own podcast right oh yeah I
have no idea I don't know a lot I think
a lot we do we've done 100 I'm probably
over like 150 150 now it's so cool yeah
we we've been doing them for a while you
got to come on in our podcast and I
would like your Instagram anything we
wanna check out my podcast it's the
views podcast it's the views podcast VI
e WS check a super super named David
Dodds Pankratz of the views podcast and
dude like I plugged in his [ __ ] name
in Google last night it was like it just
said david dobrik like main channel
youtube 7.2 billion views 7.2 billion
[Laughter]
that's that's so I mean super into
perspective how many do you have my main
channel has two hundred and eighty
million views I don't even have got like
a quarter of 1 billion he's got 7 point
it's awesome dude I am such a fan I'd am
such a fan and so grateful to be a bro
said thank you for having me on and just
inflating my ego for the last hour
you've you've really done me justice no
but I really appreciate you and thanks
for helping out the video is truly what
you're doing is is it's admirable it's
impressive
it's [ __ ] badass I'm a huge fan and
thank you brother
peace man alright so maybe I rode his
dick a lot but the kid is killing it and
I really like him and you know what I
really like you too
for hanging in there until the end of
the episode I want to show you extra
appreciation this week for doing that we
always do the street team thing where I
ask you to us
shot and post it and I'll like everyone
I see and please thank the guests for a
great episode but you know what for the
street team I'm gonna show you guys
brand-new brand-new here y'all gonna
grab that brand new wild ride t-shirts
and they are available at Stevo calm and
I'm giving the street team of promo code
you know what promo code Street team
that's with two tees all jammed into one
word street team and he get 15% off
screwed 15% off the whole damn online
store at Stevo calm promo code street
team I don't know how long I'm gonna
keep this deal going so better hurry up
and get on over there but yeah dude I
will be so stoked if I see posts and
people wearing wild ride t-shirts of
freak out like definitely I'll leave a
comment on every one of those I see and
for the some people said that they don't
that I didn't comment or like their post
[ __ ] that man I hit every single one the
problem is if you don't actually tag me
where it says tag people then I'm not
gonna see it just putting my handle and
the caption won't do the trick you got
to tag me and oh man if you're wearing a
wild ride - she'll be so stoked I'm so
stoked Donny anyway man thank you guys
for sticking through to the end I really
love you yeah dude